all right guys so you know that I am
pretty obsessed with all things electric
cars well this is super exciting Nissan
just announced a whole lineup of new
Eevee concept cars thanks to Nissan for
partnering with me on this video and
these are more than just cars they are a
vision into the future of how cars will
integrate into our lives reimagine the
way that we move and transform
sustainable Transportation this one is
the Nissan hyper Punk it's tailored
towards content creators influencers
artists it has onboard cameras that
capture the scenery around the car and
even has a mobile cre studio with bio
sensors inside of it okay look at this
one this is the Nissan hyper Adventure
it's an SUV that's designed for people
who are passionate about Outdoor
Adventures and eco-friendly lifestyle I
mean just look at this design this is so
awesome all right now this one is the
Nissan hyper Urban and this is all about
sustainability it has built-in AI that
will autonomously charge vehicles and
power buildings plus you can update the
hardware and software to keep the
experience fresh I don't think I've seen
a cooler vision for the future of
electric cars